Roblox did an oopsie.
Twitch did an oopsie.
Disney did an oopsie.
Everyone did an oopsie!
[Good Music]
***PEW NEWS*** very good news
Good evening. I'm Poppy Borger, and welcome to Pew News.
Our first story comes from  ̶F̶o̶r̶t̶n̶i̶t̶e̶  Roblox. (lol)
PewDiePie played Roblox the other day to stop T-Series.
Closing the gap over 42,000 subscribers
There was over 120,000 concurrent viewers at some point,
making it the biggest Roblox livestream of all time.
I don't know if that's true, I just think it sounds pretty epic-
Now, I go on Roblox every day
and I check out my latest creations,
and I realized that PewDiePie's account had been deleted.
( ˃̣̣̥⌓˂̣̣̥ )
hahahahahah
Offensive item
Reason: Inappropriate
pewdie123t32's Place...
...has been terminated
How could Roblox do it?
ROBLOX WOULD NEVER DO THIS
"Our content monitors have determined that your behavior at Roblox had been in violation of our Terms of Service"
WHAT!?
"Roblox banned pewdiepie for promoting them"
How could they do this?
SMH Roblox!!!
You banned PewDiePie?
Roblox is biased
Now I'm not supposed to have my opinion, but I would never be that biased.
They banned PewDiePie just because he said a couple bad words
Disgusting!
👏 PewDiePie 👏 didn't deserve to be banned
👏 Unban PewDiePie!
Now people are outraged in the Roblox community
and rightfully so.
I'm not supposed to have my opinion...
...but PewDiePie getting banned from
pew- die- pew- die- err
Roblox
Is probably the most grave offenses
that I've ever seen in our modern society.
95% and I'm not supposed to have my opinion
but I had to do it to see the poll vote, okay?
84 people have spoken.
I think it's pretty clear that PewDiePie NEEDS to get unbanned.
Now, I watched the whole livestream...
...and I don't remember saying anything bad.
I mean, what did I do?
That was so bad.
Everyone that makes an account in Roblox,
...gets their own little house,
...their own living sanctum,
...their own little heaven.
Imagine that just getting ripped away from you.
So you may think to yourself
"Well, PewDiePie must be having fun playing with his friends...
...like, his fans.
...There was nothing wrong with what he did."
Uh, uh, uh!
I think I discovered
I did some hardcore digging...
...and I think I discovered the reason behind the ban.
[Livestream Replay] Look guys I made a new friend
Uh, See that? He was caught speeding.
He went 150MPH in a 50MPH lane.
I mean, he can cry all he wants but he did violate the law.
So.....
"I watched it all, he didn't troll or anything. He had fun with fans."
And the other people said the same thing. I watched the entire livestream. He did nothing wrong.
And then people started you know going into conspiracy territory saying that
"I heard from a video that uploading anything related to Pewdiepie
On Roblox might get banned so I decided to try it out. Uploading a shirt saying "Sub To Pewdiepie"
Lo and Behold!
He got a warning.
Offensive item-Reason: Innapropriate
Sub to Pewdiepie
HoW cOuLd hE?!
So, people were still kindly curious- like why like
Why is that so bad?
And people found this post from a Roblox Staff
From January 9 saying
"Pewdiepie is no longer permitted on Roblox
due to his content
Redirecting to unsafe and inappropriate site channels.
(Pewds) What the hell does that mean?!
As well as continued inappropriate behavior
That would not be permitted on Roblox or his own channel."
So, it doesn't matter on what you do on Roblox
It doesn't matter what behavior you have on their game
Anything outside will get you banned.
"links to sites and channels" like WHAT THE HELL
What sites and channels do I link to?
They even say it themselves that "Linked websites are not under our control and,
we are not responsible for their content."
It says in their own Terms Of Service.
Which they banned me for.
How could they? I mean Pewdiepie.
How could they do this?
I've never been this outraged.
Okay, then, you need to ban 90% of people on Youtube, like
Logan Paul and VanossGaming
For saying inappropriate things, right?
It's basically the same thing.
"So bascially Roblox is saying that Youtubers with mature themes are not permitted to ever join Roblox??
Is that what they're saying?
It's annoying that fans that would just want to support me
literally get their account deleted
For adding stuff like "sub to pewdiepie"
My favorite one is this one.
"Roblox, I met PewDiePie yesterday
on Bee Swarm Simulator, greeted him."
And he got his account disabled
for saying "HI PEWDIEPIE"
in offensive item "HI PEWDIEPIE"
"HI PEWDIEPIE"
My lists of demands for the unban is simple OK
This is a letter directly to you ROBLOX
I supported you
I made the biggest Roblox livestream
and I think a lot of people can benefit from your game
but NOW I changed my mind
and I'm really angry
reinstate my Roblox private uh- game thing
123t32
not just reinstate my account
but I want at least 500 robux
as an APOLOGY!!!
and I also want
a written apology saying,
"SUBSCRIBE TO PEWDIEPIE"
to show that you don't support T-series
in all of this.....
that's my list of demands
If you don't follow ROBLOX
you're gonna be VERY mistakenly-
you're gonna be regretful OK
you're gonna be angry at YOURSELF
you're gonna regret this ROBLOX!!!
Those are my demands,
you have 25 hours.
👏NEXT NEWS👏 because I'm so angry
The new Aladdin was announced
and uhh Will Smith is on a career destroying path
at this point.
[Trailier] When he sweat the sweat run back what's
off his forehead just to stay away from his face.
was that supposed to entice people to watch the film?
Jesus Christ WHAT WAS THAT!?
What have you done to the BELOVED GENIE!?
You know there is gonna be a ton of memes
there's already a lot of memes
Colossal is Crazy posted "breaking bad deleted scene"
*pewds laughs*
*gasps*
Oh God.
"actual photo of Will Smith in the new live action Aladdin movie"
*pewds chuckles*
"This looks like a blue version of Shrek."
Yes it does!
(look at meme)
"it's not too late to just not do this"
Please Disney.......PLEASE DON'T DO THIS
👏NEXT NEWS👏
uhh Mr.Beast posted on twitter that he got this claim
which was VERY questionable
[Mr.Beast] My recent tweets have been about my videos getting claimed
and I wanna do a video to give a little more details
basically this is the old Youtube
uhh- yeah analytics which is what I used
and on this it just tells you whatever
musical composition
the record label you know
monetized by copyright owner
it doesn't give you ANY information
which is why I was always so confused
uh if we look this video is claimed by
"LIVING ON VIDEO" by Pascal Languirand
whoever that guy is so
watch the video, this is what I think they claimed me for
because we were singing this song.
(Video) Livin' on a prayer
Copy righting this makes no sense
[Mr.Beast] Didn't use a beat or anything
we just sung this song
um so I don't thing that's claimable
but whatever and then THIS Pascal guy
who doesn't even own the song
claimed it because of-
let's find his song
where is his
Right here! This one!
uhh "Living On"
I think he says "Living on" in the video
so I'm guessing we got claimed because
we said the words "Living on"
(laughs in background)
Idk I was gonna try muting it or cuting it out (other person) HOLY SHIT
but that's what I'm sayin' I just feel like-
*pewds laughs* Like you say the words
"Living on"
and you get claimed all the revenue is lost from your videos
by those simple two words
Oh God! Did I just say them!?
Like what the HELL is this Youtube system!?
It's insane!
so, it's not even the song he's referencing
but he still get's claimed for just referencing a song?
Like WHAT THE HELL is this system on Youtube
where you can do this sort of thing!?
This guy should not be allowed to upload songs on Youtube
if this is the sort of uhh way you abuse the system.
The system is there to protect people from copyrighting
and up- re-uploading other people's  content
THIS IS NOT IT.
How crazy is this!? (very ;-;)
Now, Grandayy pointed out on twitter that
uh methods that these uh companies are using
outside of Youtube are equally crazy if even crazier
bringing up uh stories like "In one case
it told a 61-year-old mechanic that he would have to
pay £150(193.46 dollars) to play his radio while he worked by himself.
It also targeted a bakery that played a radio
in a private room in the back of the shop,
*pewds gasps*
a woman who used a classical radio to calm her horses
[Pewds] had to pay up
and community centres that allowed children to sing carols in public
Like this is how copyright is used to target individuals
in abusing copyright law
Like WHAT THE HELL this is- the greed is unfath- unfathomable
I mean..this is not about protecting artists
something needs to get done!
👏NEXT NEWS👏
speaking of bad claims
questionable decisions made by every-
decisions made by everyone
not just companies but individuals in the community as  well
This time "JustDestiny"
I mean I called out youtubers for making questionable
copyright claims before
just 'cause I think it's really important like-
if companies are abusing the system
then at the very least we as individuals
or youtube creators
should NOT be abusing the system
but NO ONE LISTENS!!!
"JustDestiny" this time uh a channel with 1.7 million subscribers
he makes Dr.Phil videos
which I may or may not have gotten some inspiration from
uh but he also makes these also VERY questionable thumbnails
where he criticize really young girls
and he adds some uh in a very sexual manner in the thumbnail
"SHE'S ONLY 13"
a lot of people called out JustDestiny from this saying,
dude- like what are you doing!?
this is kind of messed up
this 15 year old kid called "LT cobra"
uhh criticized him
[LT cobra] and already the top search you get
"What Kids Are Really Doing On Musical.ly"
now without the thumbnail it've already given it away that their children
we also have KIDS in the title
so JustDestiny is fully aware that he's using the fact that
kids are being VERY sexual
to boost his views
f*ckin quailty mate.
we have this individual girl kind of moving her hair back with her t*ts out
*sighs* Destiny wh- why is this on your hard drive?
"Malu Trevejo Must Be Stopped... (Danielle Bregoli Exposed)"
t*ts in the thumbnail
not to mention the fact that this says, "SHE'S ONLY 14"
[Pewds] and low and behold JustDestiny took this video down
criticizing him
which obviously he can't do it's the Youtube system It's so fantastic
and on top of that he also sent a LAWSUIT
against this kid, this 15-year-old kid that made this video
he sent a lawsuit against for being defamatory, I think at least
KEEMSTAR even pointing out that this is a fake lawsuit
it seems to be fake and there's no listen attorney under that name
so it's basically just fake threats and scare tactics
to get this kid to uhh shut up from criticizing him
JustDestiny did a response to this
basically saying "wElL hE cAlLeD Me a pEdO"
[JustDestiny] so there is this kid called "LT cobra"
who made a video on me about 2 weeks ago
insinuating, accusing, or throwing out the conspiracy
that I may be like some type of PEDO
or knots as they call it?
SOMEHOW he came away with a conclusion and the bright idea that
he should make a video
spreading rumors, speculating and basically insinuating that
I...could possibly be a pEdO.
I think you're getting sucked JustDestiny
on the whole pedo thing
most people probably don't think you're a pedophile
most people are criticizing you
for using really REALLY young girls in a sexual manner
as a thumbnail as a way to draw people in
I mean I have a girl in my thumbnail
of this video, 'cause I know that'll get views
everyone knows how this sh*t works
but to use underage girls is VERY questionable
it's kind of a gross thing to do
and I think you deserve to be criticized for it
(👏RESPECT WAMEN 👏)
and this sh*t ain't rocket science
you know what you're doing
and even if you're denouncing it
That's just weird. This is weird.
All you really had to do in this situation was acknowledge
"Yeah you know what, that was f***ed up, I won't do it again"
And people just can't learn!
People just can't face criticism
And instead he just abuses copyright on YouTube, which is already an issue enough, to take down this kid's video
And even sending a lawsuit. It's really f***ing annoying how people keep doing this
Just STOP
like this whole thing got so much overblown
AGAIN  f*ckin reference uh- Barbra Streisand
for the f*ckin 100th time
why do I keep swearing? That's not helping, sorry.
The MORE you try to hide something on the internet
the MORE people will find it.
Just acknowledge that you were wrong and move on.
IT AIN'T THAT HARD
GODDAMN
like people are generally forgiving on the internet
just own up to your mistakes and that's it
that's all you had to do it's not like- GODDAMN
👏NEXT NEWS👏
To brighten the mood a bit Tekashi
who's who's- in jail right now I think?
before he got arrested
God Bless Him
He recorded this brand deal for Valentine's Day
and it's goddamn beautiful.
[Video] (worker) Well how can I help you guys?
(Tekashi) Yeah we ready to spice thing up ;)
(worker) You do know you have to know your partners limitations?
(Tekashi) I agree. (*pewds chuckles*)
When I was younger I used to make a lot of stupid mistakes.
(Pewds) yeah
(Tekashi) I'm ready to learn more.
(spokesperson) Get informed, help stop violence against women.
(Pewds) a oh?
(Spokesperson) Visit a Romantic Depot near you and pick up your free pamphlet.
(Tekashi) Thanks to Romantic Depot I now know how to treat women
with dignity and respect.
(narrator) Visit Romantic Depot Rockland
go to RomanticDepot.com for directions.
(Pewds) Finally Tekash, another fellow man that knows how to RESPECT WAMEN.
He has SO much respect for wamen.
That was WAY more impactful than any Gillette commercial
in just m- my opinion
👏NEXT NEWS👏
The FINAL news is about HelenaLive getting banned
uhh she got banned for basically saying "There's only 2 genders."
[HelenaLive] "Your recent behavior has proven your lack
of understanding what hateful speech is,
and how it may effect your community or your channel."
They told me that I insulted the transgender community.
"I would advise you to study our TOS and community guidelines once again and-
[Pewds] Ok so what she alleged is
I- I'm saying alleged is because I haven't seen the clip
'cause her channel is deleted
so you can't really watch it
but she said that she was just bringing up the
ideas around biology. I think she says it here?
(HelenaLive) I think that biologically there's 2 genders.
I think there's the woman and the man.
That's what biology tells us.
I specifically said it's okay if a male
wants to be a woman and a woman wants to be a man.
You can not anything in between.
I said I supported the transgender community.
I never said I didn't.
They banned me because I said there's two genders or sexes.
That's why I got permanently banned from Twitch.
Are you actually kidding me right now?
Biology with HelenaLive everyone.
Now eh heh heh
She says so apparently if you get 3 bans
you're.....off the site on Twitch.
I'm not sure if that's right.
I shouldn't say stuff that I don't know.
But she basically says that she's only been banned once.
(HelenaLive) He says several. I've been banned once.
And warned that way....
"And warned that way that the behaviour you're showing
is unfortunately not the type of content we let
live on Twitch."
You let boobs though.
You let actual naked tits.
*HAHAHAHAHA*
But you don't let conversation.
"I'm very sorry you had to come to this decision
but there's no turning back from this point and we have
finalised the process.
We hope
we can look back one day and
learn and grow from this."
(Pewds) I love...I love that...
We hope that one day we can all learn from this.
You're not allowed to have any discussions about
certain topics.
I mean I...."Proof that Twitch staff is filled with LGBT white knights."
*wheeze*
Jesus Christ
I mean the thing is you know that this is such a
sensitive topic for a lot of people,
that it's like if someone brought this up I'd kind of would
just go ehhhhh
I mean I don't know why..what the context behind this
discussion was.
I don't know why she was discussing it.
Explosives that you probably shouldn't go near.
and lo and behold here's the reason why you shouldn't.
But then again it's pretty concerning
I mean this seems to me...again I haven't watched
the footage so I don't know what she exactly said.
But if it is what she says then I mean
Twitch seems to be pretty strongly against freedom
of speech if that's the case
As long as she wasn't inciting violence or harm
against anyone, she should have every right to
express her opinion about it whether you agree with it
or not.
I- It's pretty concerning how these websites are shutting down
pe- people voicing their opinion on this subject
because it might offent a community of people
I mean...that just doesn't seem right to me.
This bending of Freedom of Speech just to appease a group of people.
we're living in really strange times right now..
really strange times
I would be concerned if I was a Twitch Streamer
*chuckles* to say the least
Jesus Christ...
I mean as much flak as I give Youtube
at LEAST I haven't seen them pull any stuff like this
I know Youtube still..
Is workin' really to pro- protect Freedom of Speech
and they know how important that is
To see Twitch make a decision like this is very concerning
I would- I would like before I express myself too much on this
to have seen what she actually said
uhh but as she pointed out herself
uhhh which was,
(HelenaLive) Not giving me access to my VOD
to PROVE to them that they're not-
that they're LYING
they're saying I don't support transgender people
when I- in that VOD
in that VOD that they banned me that I had to delete
I said I do. I am done.
at this point there is nothing I can do about Twitch
(Pewds) so there you have it
a-as far as I'm concerned I think she switched over to Youtube
man....CRAZY I can't imagine
I mean your livelihood basic- idk
is she a fu-full time livestreamer? Just getting banned?
That really sucks. OK
That it for this weeks PEW NEWS hope you guys enjoyed this video
smash like if you did!!
and uh- I as always I'm Poppy Gloria Borger Harlow
and this has been my pleasure
Good Evening, Good Night, and have a good life
[Good music]
Guys I edited subs to like 14 mintues of this video...ugh wth am I doing IM NOT EVEN GETTING PAID FOR THIS
PEW NEWS OUT!!!
[TuberSimulator Ad] You want pyramids? We got 'em!
Oh you're into castles huh?
WE GOT CHU COVERED BABYYYY
YOU WANT SOME PETS!? EASY!!
WE GOT IT ALL!!!
*GASPS* SPONSOR EAGLE!?
THIS GAME IS STILL RELEVANT GODDAMMIT!!!